what's up you little March hares huh you
little tragic rabbits you see that
orange dangler bruh you see that Kara
huh
let's give
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate ms
[Music]
we celebrate our day
celebrate
[Applause]
[Music]
and that is music that is music by the
band or the man actually Spencer Jacob
growl GRA you and he's a man and he has
that song called celebrate and and I'm
happy to be here with you guys today it
is March it is March and it is the the
it is the year 2019 and it is this is
what we got this is who we are you know
the March hares baby you know maybe
getting that that that and that carrot
that carrots always dangling in it you
noticed that there's always a carrot
like every day I wake up there's some
carrot there's that you know that little
freaking orange veggie sickle just kind
of hanging in the distance for me
whatever it is it could be you know a
financial gain it could be a love you
know I want to get a love or a sex it
could be an apology I need to make mmm
but there's always something out in
front of me that I'm moving towards
usually I think anyway I'm just trying
to think what you know it's uh yeah
there's always something out in front of
me that I'm moving towards that I want
or sometimes that I need you know but
there's always a carrot there's always a
carrot that gets get you that that is
out in front of you and sometimes there
one that you know you put out there
their goals sometimes they're ones that
that that the you know I guess ambitions
I wonder what the difference between a
goal and ambition
ago I think an ambition like drives a
goal you know cuz if you have a goal if
you want to get something you know say
if they have something and it's
somewhere and you want to get there then
that's a goal an ambition
that's the gasoline that you put in your
tank or that it's in your tank that get
you over to that something they get you
there
so ambition I think is is basically a
goals is your gasoline they get you to a
goal you got to have that ambition I
think also have no idea but yeah there's
always a carrot that kind of gets me
going and I'm just trying to right now
just make sure that my carrots are out
of a good garden that's what I'm trying
to think about because you know I just
noticed like you know recently that I
not much changes like inside them even
though some things will change or for me
will be changing on the outside of me
you know I don't know if I feel like
that the inside like that they heal or
that they do anything to the inside of
me really you know like I mean just
recently in my life you know I've had
the opportunity to start making more
money than I made last year you know
where and so that's you know and at
first you know that you know it's
exciting just and then it's you're still
just kind of like well what but what's
going on with me you know you still are
just kind of with yourself or you might
think I guess other things in my past
have been like oh I want to get a car
but then once you get in the car and
you're driving you're in the car you're
just in there so it's just like you know
if things change or more people like I
noticed get excited like especially the
past couple weeks I've just noticed more
like I got into an uber the other day
and the drive
and now this guy was from another look
I've been in a lot of other countries
this guy thinking from like another
planet boy this dude was from you know
Mars gannis standin Avia
you know this guy was from another I
don't know he might have been you know
he might have caught up you know he
might have had a hit of that frickin
scientism or something I don't know
where this this guy was from like he
might have been raised in a sand castle
you know drinking olive juice he had a
real you know I don't you know he might
have you know went to summer camp on the
rings of Saturn this boy I don't know
what he was doing but he he's like oh I
I recognized you from hot ones and hot
ones is a chicken you know it's like a
poultry kind of passion project of a
company and I went in there last weekend
ate chicken wings with them and you go
in there and eat the wings and then and
it's hot I'm gonna put up a behind the
scenes video today of uh of how my mouth
got kind of burnt out around the edges
you know look like I've been trying to
uh you know [ __ ] French kiss a candle
I was pretty you know I was kind of very
I had a lot of different colors around
my mouth I was starting to really
ROYGBIV around the lips you know it but
um anyway I got into this uber and the
man recognized me from there and knew me
from there and it was and I just would
never have expected it it wasn't and I
was just like oh wow you know that's uh
you know it's it's exciting you know
it's let me think about what this is and
I'm not trying to brag about this I'm
trying to like I'm not trying to brag
like Oh somebody recognized me from my
comedy or from something at some place
they saw me I'm trying to think about
you know there are times when I would
think like Oh being popular or being
having people acknowledge you
[Music]
that would you know that would cure
things or that would make things
different for me or different I don't
know but that's a carrot that's out
there on notice you know that celebrity
that popularity and I don't even think
celebrity seems so someone that's a
celebrity that [ __ ] seems scary to me
because that kind of stuff is you're
like it seem like you're controlled by
bigger things you know like advertisers
and and you have to answer two different
larger groups that are in control of you
are in control of more of your time and
and things you can say
but popularity that's something that I
was like well that's like a carrot
that's kind of been out there in my life
that you know if people knew me then I
would feel maybe I wouldn't feel some of
the ways when I feel uncomfortable or
maybe it would be a solution or maybe it
would I don't know what I'm trying to
say I mean I do but I don't but this is
just something that was I was really
thinking about once this may it was just
a man that I was like I you know I never
expected that that man would say that
and he said the hot ones you know and I
guess something people on the internet
like to watch people eat I mean people
do there's a couple of dark I went down
some dark holes the other night you
could watch you know I mean and look
I'll admit it you know I like watching
you know when I was growing up I had a
couple of you know urban friends a
couple african-american buddies and if
you haven't seen them really get into
some good animal meat or some good rib
meat then you don't you know you haven't
really seen that much you know what I'm
saying these boys got that Dyson Rus
like watching a Dyson it's like watching
a Dyson [ __ ] you know dissect a UH
it's like what you I don't know what
it's like watching a damn Dyson you know
if you got a black buddy and you put him
on a set of ribs Sonny
it's [ __ ] game over dog I mean this
guy's coming in and he they just they
got more of a it's like my black friends
that seemed like they had like Fink like
hands in their lips they go [ __ ] you
know like damn bra started sometime I
would feel bad for the UH coward or the
pig the ribs are like god damn that
animals feeling that in the afterlife
you know cuz you just want I mean this
guy I mean I had a black but he could
moonwalk his his his face kind of down
the rib you know when they you know and
I'm not saying white guys can't do it
I'm not making this isn't a racial thing
but some people are better at some
things maybe or some people that's just
my experience you know like I've seen
they got that dude Yaya she the [ __ ]
hotdog monster and if you haven't seen
this dude man usually 4th of July people
out there you know you're out there
little Randall's out there [ __ ] lying
to people and selling on you know fake
grams of coke and [ __ ] out there by the
parade route and you got little daniels
out there with his fireworks and some of
me made himself you know and some of
them do you [ __ ] light him and
nothing happens point and then it just
kind of and then like a kidnap personal
pop out of one of them and you're like
then what the [ __ ] Daniel you've been up
to some dirty tricks but everybody has
their own fourth of July thing and that
guy y'all be yah she is a I don't know
man it looked like he used to do karate
and one day he just kicked a whole bunch
of [ __ ] wet hot dogs into his mouth
and he's the champ and he's the number
one champion bruh I mean this is dude
this is this dude is the Asian Abraham
Lincoln of [ __ ] you know questionable
meets this dude he one time he had likes
I'm sorry adjectives sir my phone just
did something one time yeah beyond she
had 40 or 79 freaking wet hotdogs and
that's but that's what he does on the
4th of July he goes wet hotdogs in and
that's crazy you know to me that's crazy
but you know different people do
different things anyway I'm just saying
that that guy can do hot dogs right I've
seen that and if you have ah and if you
ever had any black friends growing up
maybe you did maybe you didn't now some
some black guys aren't good at eating
stuff you know sometimes you need a real
I mean if you've ever seen a um you know
I saw a little asian girl eat a piece of
cake one time huge piece and she I mean
dude this [ __ ] look like you're [ __ ]
we're gonna take her you know two and a
half weeks I mean I was like damn I
can't even I watched for maybe about 30
minutes you know but I can't watch it it
was cool but I wasn't gonna watch
forever but what I'm saying is what am I
saying in Jesus Christ man god I think I
went down my own world my home worm hole
inside of my head but different people
do different things and so I have a
memory when I was young what was I
talking about people eating stuff some
people are better I have the experience
of seeing some people eat things better
than others I was talking about um was i
eating something Oh carrots but I don't
know I don't know how I got so laws but
anyway what I was originally trying to
talk about or what I was thinking about
was oh there's these different oh that
guy when I got in I never thought that
this guy in uber the driver was gonna be
like oh I seen this boy eat some poultry
on the internet you know I've seen this
boy [ __ ] lipping down a couple of
[ __ ] pheasant wings on it on the whip
on the on the web but that's what
happened so then yeah like it just like
I was thinking about popularity
and yeah I guess always in my life I
thought that or maybe there was this
thing that if you have you were popular
if people liked you maybe I'm trying to
think when I was young you know cuz I
like to make people laugh and I'm just
trying to think about why I like what
did I think that that pot like I guess I
don't know if I ever was had a I wanted
to be liked I guess I'm trying to think
of what I if when I was young if I had
if I had aims to be popular or if I
wanted to be liked
like what and sorry to be thinking about
all this mom but this just been what
it's on my mind I know you know I'm not
sorry you know this is what I'm this is
what's on my mind and this is honestly
the first moment I've had in four days
to think about you know things it was
just a busy for days and you know when
we went to dinner did a wonderful
weekend in San Jose I mean this dude
Leonel brought out a prairie dog and God
dang but I forgot how beautiful they are
my god
and it was nice a man he came out Late
Show on Thursday and he brought up that
[ __ ] a little pdz son you know that
little ain't talking police department
boy I'm talking peridot and they're
beautiful and you don't see a lot of
them and I asked him where he got and he
wouldn't tell me which if you own in
bootleg prairie dogs that's the right
answer
I mean I don't think he had any
documents you know I don't think he had
any documentation any documentation on
that Prairie Dee but a beautiful animal
man let me hold it and and Thank You
Leonel for coming out with that and he
gave me a also does music and he gave me
an album and that's and that kind of
sums up San Jose in some ways man you
know you don't know what the [ __ ]
somebody's doing they hand you a pretty
you know they put that prairie dog on
your shoulder and and [ __ ] hit you
with that mixtape and its diverse there
I mean this is the most diverse place
I've ever seen you know
you couldn't I mean you couldn't even be
racist if you wanted to because you
couldn't figure out who to hate you
you'd have to have a [ __ ] chart I
mean you'd have to have somebody
spotting you a lot of racial knowledge
to really be hateful so it was awesome
man and I felt a lot of love men and a
lot of support from all types of people
man all ethnicities and and a lot of
beautiful Latinos came out with their
their spouses we had some mothers and
sons that came out a couple twins came
out and I almost made him fight because
you know how I feel about twins but do
one of y'all is really living in one of
y'all this milling around you know cuz
money how him really supposed to be here
buddy
you know sometimes science kind of you
know the gear slips when science is
shifting sometimes he get that gear [ __ ]
that gear slips and you know sometime
it's like when you go to McDonald's and
you ordered a hot cheeseburger and you
open the bag at home and they got a
[ __ ] cheeseburger and a stray little
nugget in there that's twins when he
all's that fricking embora Gaza and one
of y'all is that new get that boil that
nugget so I wanted to have them fight
her arm wrestle or do a couple of
questionnaires or something and see
who's really supposed to be that boss
out of twins because twins you know is
and it's crazy like one of them always
has half of the stuff and one of them
have the other half of the stuff that
you need so you got to get a little
information over here and a little
information over here just to figure out
what the [ __ ] they've been doing either
one of them you know it's almost like
you got to be a detective to even be
friends with twins because you got to be
like okay and we tell me this and we
tell me that and the rest of it so but
they were nice guys but
lot of Mets and Tongans and dude I
thought tongue and honestly man when I
was really young I thought Tongans were
silverware big silverware sometimes you
would go to a special deal and they
would have somebody put them big tongue
and in the salad bowl you'd be like damn
these people [ __ ] rich bro you know
I'm about to sneak off to the on the way
to the bathroom I steal a damn
candelabra did I remember meaning some
rich people's house when I was young and
I would still they had potpourri a
little stack of potpourri and it
basically potpourri is like um it's
almost like the Queen of England just
gave you a little you know couple half
ounces of a couple ounces of her garden
or raked up a pile of leaves and it's
like Queen Elizabeth raked up some
leaves in her garden and then you know
sent you a couple grams of it and rich
people will set it on the top of the
toilet to show you that they got that
you know they got that Flossie you know
post life foliage and so I go in there
first time I [ __ ] fill my pockets
with that [ __ ] boy go home and it's rub
both of my pockets as much as I could
and then all this rosary like rosy type
of smell would just just permeate my
room and just really you know just made
me feel like I was back at like those
rich people's houses sometimes you know
and uh yeah I used to do weird [ __ ] like
that I guess to just have a different
experience you know but but anyway yeah
thank you for everybody that came out
man just a lot of real love of me not so
many loving people and I know this
sounds crazy but just good people good
people and I'm happy to be part of such
a group a lot of this past weekend
listeners and you know what I don't want
you to feel I don't want you to feel
like when you see me that I think any
different than you or that I think that
I'm any better than you just because you
know at the shows I'm the person that's
onstage but I do feel like a
representative of our group and I don't
know what that I don't know what some of
that means but I'm just grateful to to
be a part of it and manage it just
because I can't tell you I've been
involved in different things in my life
where yeah I don't know where I've just
never gotten to meet so many neat people
at once and somebody gots a prairie-dog
so you know that's [ __ ] a rare cuz
dude let me tell you that there ain't no
animals living on the streets of San
Jose I don't even see a bird all weekend
I mean they got people [ __ ] lasso and
[ __ ] crows right I mean you'll see a
dude with a fishing line with a worm on
it and he'll cast that [ __ ] up into the
sky and catch a [ __ ] dirty little you
know catch a dirty little dove I mean
people you know it's that it's al it's
got that little bit of Vietnam going on
where people you know you eat things
things ain't just milling around that's
like in South Africa you like in America
you have caterpillars on the sidewalk
dog that and in you go to Cape Town you
go to Johannes Berg
that's a damn [ __ ] a little side item
walking by you go to a um you know you
go to some of the villages there and
they will have a whole bowl of
Caterpillar and they cooked them out
crickets I've been there I'm not joking
about this but that's see we're in
America we'll let a [ __ ] side item
will let appetiser live on the streets
but in San Jose boy you'll see somebody
[ __ ] you know you know uh hooker
[ __ ] maybe a little gram of coke and
a Mac nugget onto a fishing hook and
then just cast that [ __ ] down an alley
and catch him a [ __ ] little you know
a little homeless person or something or
catch them a little [ __ ]
vagrant so it's a different it's a
unique place but a lot of wonderful
people and thank you guys for coming out
but what I guess what I'm trying to
think about a little bit while I just
want to think about this for a few more
minutes then we'll get into some calls
and because I'm just trying to think
like when I was young just because I
guess I you know it's just a little
scary this past week was a little you
know you just get more popular and it's
exciting you know it's or that's what it
felt like to me and some of this could
be just my feelings it could be
misinterpretation of things but it was
you know and it's exciting I'm grateful
that people come out because I love to
perform stand-up comedy and I hope that
you know always have stories and and
funny things to make people laugh it's
fun when you're in a big room and
everybody's laughing you know it makes
me I think it's probably what I always
wanted you know it's probably the thing
that made me the most happy when I was
young and in middle school over there at
CJ Shan middle and over there ah and um
at William Picher junior hired off
Jefferson Avenue they that was the
funnest thing making people laugh
sitting at the lunch table drinking milk
out of a bag that's back when they had
and they used to have the big bag and
you could all put a straw in it but and
then they would get you a little bag
you'd have your own little bag but but
it was fun him and you and when kids you
can make a kid laugh and milk will shoot
out of his nose out of his orifices
breath and that [ __ ] it's now it's like
perverted now it's something like some
of these rich men are doing out here in
the Hollywood Hills and [ __ ] and doing
it on the DL but when I was young it was
just something we would do for fun make
each other laugh so hard that milk would
you know just find its way out of our
bodies really fast and uh what else man
I'm talking about but I guess I'm just
thinking about
what you know I just I love the
experience that I've been having getting
them entertained people and uh I just
don't want you when you come to my shows
I don't want you to think just don't you
could think whatever you want
you know I guess it's just I'm not
telling anybody what to do I just I'm
grateful for people coming out that's
what I'm trying to say and it's been
exciting and and being pet it you know
being just when that man Rekha
recognized me or note you know
acknowledged me it it just surprised me
and then I was like okay this is
starting to feel a little bit different
you know this is a you know this is a I
just never thought this person would
know who I am and and not that it
matters it doesn't mean anything but it
just you know it just I don't know it
just made me think about like what's the
value maybe in in popularity you know
what's the value in it does it because I
guess what I'm starting to say is it for
me it I feel like it hasn't it doesn't
make me feel any different you know I
still and I don't want it to that's what
I'm saying you know the ego just seems
so dangerous and it just seems dangerous
and it seems so self-serving and it's
like you know you just see so much greed
out there you know even you open the
newspaper you see agreed you know you
see these you know to me it seems like
news networks are demanding what the
government should do and and it's just
because of money people are just being
greedy and you know you just see people
say you know I just want to be aware of
what my carrots are I guess you know I
just want to be aware of what my carrots
are what is driving me over here what is
making me
and I just want them to come out of a
good garden you know and and and that's
that's I guess what I'm thinking about
sorry to go in that long tangent but I
just want to know what my I want to be
conscious of what my carrots are because
a lot of times in our life we can be or
a lot of times in my life I've been led
towards carrots that I didn't even know
what they were made out of or who put
them there what was going on you know in
it and uh and those carrots can be
anything they can be money they could be
fame they could be you know it could be
power and I just you we just need to be
or I need to be conscious of what the
carrots are in my in my world and that I
don't get you know just I just said I
don't be chasing the dirty carrots you
know I don't want no dirty carrots David
I don't want no baby carrots you feel me
I ain't trying to do anything like that
like some of these rich people in the
Hollywood Hills they'll be ordering you
know baby carrots you're like damn how
many you gonna have today buddy
seem like you've had a few too many if
you're not a real baby but I just want
to be conscious of my carrots man but I
felt like I was in a beautiful garden
this weekend over there it was a cool
man you know I didn't know the world was
I mean I know the world is diverse but
damn bro San Jose he's got a lock on it
they had 700 different tents of skin
over there they had people with
mustaches one dude had a mustache above
each eye I was like all like your
eyebrows he's like those are mustaches
Papa like now okay boy I like them
[ __ ] little uh I like those little
eye Stoppers you got daddy there's
little [ __ ] uh there's little sight
burns I like this little sight burns and
yeah said that joke twice because I
wanted you to get it thank you guys for
being here and welcome to this past
weekend I'm going to Phoenix this week
and um and you know I appreciate you
guys letting me ramble on this podcast
and just talk about my feelings because
sometimes I don't know what they are and
sometimes I don't know what's going on
with me and um and I was listening to an
old episode the other day because I just
want to know I don't know I just want to
kind of hear you know take a look at
moments from the past and see moments
now and see just so I can be aware you
know I want to be aware of what's going
on I don't want to aim lessly just live
in this world and I don't want to you
know I just want to do my best and I
know I am I'm not trying to put extra
pressure on myself but I am trying to be
aware of my carrots you know that's what
I'm trying to do right now for me what
else I got to tell you this that this
episode is brought to you by grey block
pizza grey block pizza in Los Angeles
and we have a lot of listeners that stop
by there and send me JPEGs and images
and stuff like that and that's beautiful
and great block Beach is a great place
to get pizza and it's called grey block
in Los Angeles I also want you to know
this episode is brought to you by hair
club and when I was young that my mom
had the club remember the club dude the
club the club was this thing you put on
a car and you put the Alaia t8 you had
to like click it a couple certain ways
and just lock it and uh dude my mom was
so crazy about things getting stolen all
the time she didn't want and the car was
a piece of [ __ ] man you know mom had
this Ford Festiva for a little while and
she had a Volkswagen Rabbit and it was
our car man it was real real small like
the interior of the car was probably you
know probably uh maybe five or maybe
twenty square feet inside so five feet
by four feet and it's at five people boy
so it was it was like being stuck in a
really small elevator but you guys were
going somewhere forward you know and
there was a window on the front and mom
could the good thing about a small car
mom could beat everybody's ass from that
driver's seat you know cuz mom had four
children I was one of the children and
you know she went from oldest to
youngest you know and it was almost like
playing the cymbals when mom would start
whooping everybody's ass in the car
because different children have
different densities in them and that's
called body density and so she'd hit my
brother and he'd be like BAM and then me
you'd be like bang and then my sister
black thing because it was younger and
then the little baby should be like the
baby was being bad right there my
brother wouldn't shut up and they hit
him and then I start popping off you be
like and my sister was pretty good and
so sometimes she would just tap her um
but it was a UH you know that's a mom we
just start whoo and she start just
hitting the [ __ ] drums do like Larry
Kravitz you know like damn Def Leppard
God died just like that [ __ ] you know
she would go hard but anyway what was I
even talking about I don't talking about
today oh but she had the club on that
car mom dude they had wiring hanging out
of that thing one side of the car you
could see the wooden there was a little
bit of floorboard missing somebody's
stolen a piece of the floorboard welder
had cut it out and put it in their car
used it for something they needed it for
that was more important then what we
needed it for so you had in the front
you had to be careful yet to put your
feet off to the sides a little because
part of that floorboard somebody had to
borrowed it but what I'm talking about
is hair club and your confidence is
important sometimes one change can make
all the difference
hair club knows this and they're
inviting you to become part of the hair
club family to see how getting the most
out of your hair can change your life
hair club understands the emotions
you're feeling and know the questions
you have it's the leader in total hair
solutions with a legacy of success for
over 40 years whether you're looking to
revitalize the growth of your own hair
or to learn more about the latest proven
methods for hair replacement or
restoration hair clubs professionally
trained stylist experts and consultants
will craft a solution to ensure you feel
your best and get the most out of your
hair I have you know a lot of our
listeners know I had a hair transplant
I had like 50 hairs taken out of the
back and put in those little you know
those little slither and spaces up there
them a little you know those Dracula
points a couple years ago or a year year
ago now two years ago and it was a for
me it was a good experience you know and
so anyway I've had some experience with
you know dealing with my hair and just
wanting to keep hair you know wanting to
keep hair on my head because I used to
farm and you know a man is often you
know a man can sometimes you know what
we're just if you've ever farmed you
want to [ __ ] have a little crop you
want to be you know have that crop top
willis Brun so that's what I had but you
can go to hair club.com slash Theo today
for a free hair analysis and a free
take-home hair kit all valued at over
$300 that's hair club.com
slash Theo for a free hair analysis and
free hair kit hair club comm / Theo
experience your hair and your life at
its best
only with hair club I'm certain you'll
love the club and yeah mom used to put
that club on that car and we would all
laugh and man because the car was a
piece of [ __ ] do we own the car and we
would always hope people would steal it
you know we'd rather walk in an
organized group with mom walking and
then one of us walking right next to her
and then three of us walking in the back
right behind her we don't we'd rather
walk in formation than be in that car
because you knew if we was going
somewhere or long enough over probably a
mile and a half mom was about to play
that hangout drums boy everybody's gonna
get they ass made and I don't knock my
mother for that you know when a widowed
mother is a single mother they have to
be a father to they have to be a
disciplinarian
and uh that's another thing I was think
about this weekend you know it's
interesting a lot of my generation our
mother had to also be a disciplinarian
and I just wonder the effects of when
you have to when you I don't know if a
young man is supposed to or young well I
can't speak for a young woman I don't
know I can't speak for anybody I don't
know if I I don't know how I don't know
how I don't know if a mother is supposed
to have to be that you know somewhat yes
but I don't know and maybe that's just
been historically maybe in the future
that will change as our DNA gets
different ideas stuck into it and moving
forward but but I don't know how a young
man takes that if the mother also has to
be the disciplinarian
because then sometimes you might not go
to your disciplinarian to get the love
you need and so then if you all if you
see your mother as a disciplinarian then
when you need a hug maybe you know you
don't get that you don't go get the hug
because you don't want to go hug
somebody that it was also having to be a
disciplinarian to you out of some type
of a spite maybe you know like say you
do rocked you out at the schoolyard a
little you know popped you off say
somebody [ __ ] hit you with a
broomstick you know or [ __ ] you know
put a couple pieces ice in your mouth
and and just made you know just punched
you in the face until you is just
serving just shaved ice right out of
your own face bro welcome to Oahu but
later in the day you're gonna go hug
that guy when you need some emotional
support when you need a tender moment
are you gonna do that you know so I
think that's some of the things when I'm
just starting to think I've been
thinking about like what happens when
you know when children have to be raised
by single parents and how they interact
with one another and you know I don't
have the knowledge about it so I'm not
able to sometimes come from a place of
knowledge and so if you think that I
know what I'm talking about then don't
think that because that's not what I'm
trying to say I'm just trying to talk
about
whatever I'm you know some of my
experience but anyway I also want to let
you know that this past weekend has
brought to you by skills share skill
shares an online learning community for
creators with more than 25,000 classes
and design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start asad hustle
or gain new professional skills
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
thriving and reaching those new goals
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just from our listeners
get two months of Skillshare for free
think of all the skills yep
they can be free that's right skill
share is offering tpw listeners two
months of unlimited access go to skills
share comm Theo von to start your two
months now that's skill share calm slash
Theo von it might be a nice gift if you
have you know some a child or sibling
that's that's always on their device get
that get them that educational hitter
because if they're already on there if
they're on a tablet or something they
might not mind learning while they are
but they might you know but yeah I guess
I'll just you know a lot of intro not
introspection I don't just a lot of
thinking this week you know because uh
you know I just I just this is the first
weekend where I started to notice like
man like people or it just felt like
more popularity and so I just wanted to
and you know it in it's great look I
love meeting people I love meeting
like-minded people I feel like a lot of
the people that come to the you know to
the comedy shows like we're kind of
like-minded you know even and when we
were talking to her in line and I tried
to meet everybody I could some of the
early shows I couldn't but the late
shows I try to meet every single person
and you know even just the sometimes the
short conversations or just the look in
our eyes to each other and that you know
it felt like we were like-minded and so
I'm just happy to be able to meet people
that it would seem like I would meet
anyway you know we just meet up at a
comedy show I don't want to talk about
my mine's a little all over the place oh
I got a lot of people that reached out
you know I was all stopped into this pet
the fighter and the kid the other day
and had a you know and I had a nice chat
in there with Brian Callens and he is if
you're not familiar with him he was I
don't think he was in the Old Testament
but he was in the New Testament and he
was a Jedi or something I don't know
what he was but he he's seen many many
moons
you know Native Americans know him
there's drawing of hims on there's
drawings of him on hims probably the
producer you know there's leaner pilled
boy does giraffe makers
there's drawings of him on on cave walls
and these aren't rumors these are real
things if you put your ear up to a
seashell that you find on a mountain you
can hear it ask for Bryan Callen you
know there's a lot of crazy things like
um apparently one time a huge wave came
and and at the same time a rainbow was
shooting through the sky and the wave
was like a hundred feet high and at the
same moment an eagle flew right in and
there was like a triumvirate of water
and and and rainbow and Annie Galatea
and that they say is when Bryan Callen
so he's a very fascinating man but I
stopped in there and I we we had to like
kind of a we had kind of a you know an
unemotional coming up we had a kind of a
Rhett you know a real conversation I was
just thinking about stuff and they were
super helpful and you know and Brendon
you know because I get you know I don't
get god I guess I get caught on my
feelings a little bit but I like it you
know sometimes I like to know what's
going on with my feelings because when I
was young I didn't have a lot of
feelings the only feelings I had a lot
of times were you know anger or you know
inferiority
you know self-doubt self-loathing and so
for me in the past three years of my
life I've been able to have different
feelings you know and and some of that
it you know it takes some navigation in
it and and but anyway I had a lot of
people send really nice messages isn't
just supportive type of stuff and I just
want to say thank you for that you know
I'm not trying to be this emo guy that's
out here [ __ ] wine and then [ __ ] like
that and [ __ ] you know throwing uh
you know throwing [ __ ] you know dirty
[Music]
handkerchiefs down a wishing well or
something but but whatever man that you
know I like to think about what I'm
feeling or feel about what I'm thinking
and and that's how there's nothing I can
do about it you know that's who I am and
sometimes it's it's fun and sometimes
it's it's it's it's not as much fun you
know and sometimes you know but I'm
grateful that I had people like those
guys I stopped in and there was a nice
thing that Brendan said you know he said
hey man the other day I felt like you
weren't feeling that good and uh he goes
and I felt bad because I didn't know how
I didn't know what to say to make you
feel better
and and you know I thought that was one
of the most touching things that I'd
really heard you know burned it or not
joke around a lot you know we we do the
podcast called King in the sting and we
joke around a lot him
but I thought that was a very you know a
night it was just a it was a very nice
thing for him to say you know he said he
grew up and his mom was you know his mom
suffer from some addiction issues and
and he'd never knew how to talk to her
to make her feel better you know and uh
and he just that it just him saying that
made me just you know I stopped even
then I just you know you just know right
then that you have friends and people
around you to talk to and that have your
back
and that's what it is that's you know
that's all you can ask when you're
having times where you're going through
some tough moment system is someone to
be there to listen to you and and just
try and help you make you feel okay and
I got a lot of that from you know from
the listeners and also from just
stopping in there and Brian is so smart
man isn't he and he's so brave about you
know just this is who I am you know he
says and this is and I'm gonna have
times like this and I'm gonna have times
like that but this is who I am and this
is the path that I'm on and I mean he
has such a great energy and I hear from
everybody that that comes out and that
has seen a lot of comedians and they
they often comment on how much fun his
show is he has both of those guys have
unique gifts inside of them to make
other people feel happy do you notice
that I think that's why people love the
fighter and the kid and I'm grateful to
them I you know except for when they're
loud and through this [ __ ] wall dude
and I swear to god boy huh if this batch
of head lice comes in that I ordered off
the internet boy and I'm talking big
head lights do it I ordered a [ __ ]
half a jar from Zhai air and when those
get from wherever they are to Zhai air
I'm gonna sneak them into their studio
boy
it's gonna be the fighter and the NYX
NYX was an old thing needs to have to
get rid of head lice anyway man this
episode is longer than I thought I
thought it was gonna be sure but it's
okay I thought something was gonna be
something didn't that funny
I had a plan Shh ah we can't have a man
we can try but you know apparently uh
life had a bigger carrot out in front of
me today which was to be here Robin Hood
is an investing app that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos
all commission-free while other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade Robin Hood doesn't charge any
Commission fees so you can trade stocks
and keep all your profits you deserve
that plus there is no account minimum
deposit needed to get started so you can
start investing at any level the simple
intuitive design of Robin Hood makes
investing easy for newcomers and experts
alike view easy-to-understand charts and
market data and place a trade in just
four taps on your smartphone think about
that
that's just like mom you know hitting us
in the car when seven shares of Apple
you can view stock collections such as
100 most popular with Robin Hood you can
learn how to invest in the market as you
build your portfolio discover new stocks
track your favorite companies and get
custom notifications for price movements
so you never miss the right moment to
invest Robin Hood is giving listeners of
this past weekend a free stock like
Apple Ford or sprint to help you build
your portfolio
sign up at Weekend dot Robin Hood
dot-com
that's weekend dot Robin Hood dot-com
and these days I think you know I've had
experience over the years with investing
and I find it instead of using a broker
and doing that sort of thing I find it
pretty manageable to do by oneself but
if it's not for you
there may be tools here on Robin Hood or
you may want to go the old-fashioned
around and get a broker but but this is
an option and this apparently from
everyone that I'm hearing is is the way
to keep most your money yourself and not
have to pay fees I'm gonna let you guys
know that I'm going to be in Phoenix
Arizona this weekend and then I'll be in
Kansas City Missouri the weekend after
April 26 and 27 then Palm Beach May 3rd
and 4th Caroline's in New York City and
I think we added a Sunday show this
weekend I'm not sure about some others
did eight shows this past weekend in San
Jose and it was a lot and so I think
some of that is why I'm feeling a little
kind of you know just all over the place
it was a lot it was just it was just a
lot you know and and then by the end of
the last show I just was kind of I could
barely even talk anymore my face was
just tired from talking on stage and
from talking just communicating and it
was just after the shows and it was just
a lot man but thank you so much for
coming out I thought that the theatre
right there they have is beautiful and
that some people don't know the San Jose
that theater there Harry Houdini
performed in it in Harry Houdini
that's the magician and he performed
there let's get into a little news
really quick United Airlines now offers
non-binary gender options for travelers
booking flights so you can say your mail
you can say your female you can say
undisclosed or even X unspecified and
we'll also have the option to choose the
title MX now I'll say it is dads nope
you can be basically you could be you
could be Clark damn Kent that should be
an option you know I want to be Clark
Kent I want to be a butterfly you know I
want to be Nickelback you should be able
to choose any option you want on there
why stop it undisclosed on
if I Brian don't be undisclosed disclose
your boat you know get on there say you
might have you know you might you you
about 40 percent male 60 percent female
you know just at least you know let me
know the odds or who's maybe next to me
a little not cuz I need not because but
just let me know you know I'm saying
tell me if you might be you know thirty
percent carnival worker so in case you
break out [ __ ] you know in case you
set a couple of little you know goldfish
bowls on the thing and start shooting
off ping-pong balls out of your face
trying to win a big [ __ ] Chester
cheater that's fake it's not it's never
Chester you see the thing at the fair
it's always like Chauncey cheetah and
it's like it looks like chester Cheetah
from the chip bag but he got that [ __ ]
cigarette or he's hiding a little gram
back there by his tail but I ever seen
Chauncey cheetah boy Chauncey cheetah he
[ __ ] around oh he's got those
deadbeat dad papers in his pocket boy
and that's how you win at that carnival
you get that you know you get that
goldfish when you get that hitter but at
least let me know if I'm sitting next to
you know forty percent man 17 percent
woman and then 30 / 30 33 percent
carnival worker so we can know what's
going on but yeah I'm choosing MX boy
unspecified unspecified oh yeah dr. Dre
should be an option [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] 20
percent dr. Dre today you know I'm 30
percent 50 cent you can find me in the
[ __ ] club baby
so anyway if you want to be whoever you
want to be in the skies fly United do it
also they should put in there with the
Lord so I could put I'm a hundred
percent with the Lord and that sucker
just in case that plane gets a little
you know flashy crash you off some
Lightning then then anything and God's
looking through the freaking uh the seed
of Dex to see who's sitting where he's
gonna be like that's my little on hell
right there that's me at a mano de
sub-domain go that's me unn Hill right
there
that boy's a hundred percent with a lot
so I go straight from the plane to the
heaven you feel me and that's a pretty
bad rhyme and I'm sorry about that what
else a beautiful video of a soldier
returning home and surprising his son at
Taekwondo practice went viral I was a
touching the hearts of many I haven't
seen this but I heard about it
Staff Sergeant Rob's s Torino had been
gone for ten months serving overseas for
the Tennessee National Guard and
surprised his nine year old son Luca by
coming home early
the family was first row for the UFC
fight in Nashville on Saturday wow
that's awesome
it gives me chills you know it gives me
chills because say what you know people
there's all types of people serve in the
US military
all types people that want to make a
better opportunity for their family
people that sometimes don't have a
choice he they you know they almost have
to go there they're going to jail so you
got them Vic's boy them see Vic's you
know convicts people that love and want
to support and fight for our country or
defend our country people that believe
that they people who are willing to put
their existence in front
of their freedom and that's always
fascinating to me and I love these
videos you know cuz I think it's it just
it shows a lot you know it shows a lot
of the human condition you know it shows
like longing it shows a commitment the
father has commit you know committed to
his time if there's a sense of honor
because the you know the parent that's
returning usually has on a military you
know garment for their country and we
can all a lot of us can relate to being
a nine-year-old hopefully I mean
hopefully there's no eight-year-olds
listening to this show but that's always
a touching moment when you see that and
yeah that's fun I haven't seen this one
but I'm looking forward to it
what else we got someone else Oh Robert
Miller suspends special counsels Russia
probe report to Attorney General I never
thought that Russia had anything to do
with anything to be honest with you I
just never got that vibe do I think that
everybody's using dirty [ __ ] on Facebook
yes
do I feel like if I start thinking about
a pair of shoes next thing you know I
turn my head and I'll see nine
smoking-hot women who don't even live in
my town and who have never even existed
before suddenly walking behind wearing
the exact same shoes that I want and
maybe even like a little cat like a cat
and he gets on four little bitty same
shoes exactly as I want and all of them
have like a little microchip that's
owned by Facebook built into their back
do I think that kind of [ __ ] happens to
me a lot I notice that I feel like so I
think everybody's after our brain stems
I think everybody is trying to convince
us to do everything but I just it just I
don't know I don't know what I think
about this kind of stuff I just think
that it's amazing I think it's
unfortunate that the FBI had was on this
track for two years
you know but I guess it's a serious
issue if somebody if there really is you
know severe tampering with election then
that's necessary but I just don't see
how you would do it people have to go
vote people human being have to walk
over there with the voter with the peace
with the peace with the so you know I
can't even be just the the energy
everyone had to spend dealing with this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
think about the FBI how many how many
how many people have come into the
country who have ill-will how many
children may have gone missing how many
different things may have happened
because they were on this goose chase
for two years
I don't know and also I don't know a ton
about stuff you know what a lot a ton of
like political stuff but for me I never
felt like there was a a collusion it
always seemed like a bunch of [ __ ]
to me because there was so much
advertising around it by the news it was
just such a constant thing but I never
it never seemed like there was enough
grit to it you know I just feel like we
could spend our time doing a lot more
important things but I don't let
politicians run my life you know I run
my life you know I don't need you know
none of those decisions any of those and
any political parties ever made have
affected what I do you know if I work
hard I believe if you work hard and you
try harder in this country that you can
get you can you can get your carrots man
you can get your carrots you can reach
them you
I hear that from a lot of like speaking
of uber drivers and kind of almost going
full circle here you hear that from a
lot of uber drivers you and and here in
in Los Angeles you get a lot of guys
from other countries that come in and
you know first generation just got here
you know will drive uber and you hear a
lot of them that this is the opportunity
they're here for the opportunity and and
I believe it you know I feel like once
you start expecting the government to
can run your lot or like if you lean it
on the government dude it's okay I'm not
saying you're there's anything wrong
with you and I shouldn't really be
saying that but I think you'll have bet
for me I believe you'll have better luck
leaning on yourself I think you had
there's a lot much less red tape and I
believe you can do it if you're having
trouble doing it what else man let's uh
[Music]
hey Arlene
sorry guys had a call supposed to be on
a call right there and uh and so I had
to take that I want to tell you though
that let's take a couple of calls
speaking of calls man I felt like I was
right in the middle of thinking about
something that's life okay Paola and
that is Brazil huh I think Paola may be
I have no idea um thank you for calling
lo P let's hear more okay okay little
mommy got a couple of mo spring are you
running them spring around him off
spreesy
let's go just call me cuz I just saw
your show like this San Jose improv and
just wanted to give you props I really
appreciate you I really appreciate your
dark art tour and I have a serious
question for you because I've been
working out but uh my booty still don't
look as good as yours and I just want to
know what type of exercises you do to
get that booty poppin I really need
that booty-popping I don't even know
what what it is um I don't have nothing
you know I came out you know what I'm
saying why I grew up in a you know kind
of like a that stray animal belt and so
when you got that you know okay
a lot of over the generations you never
know maybe a man will slip in there a
woman you know maybe somebody a little
steed or something you know a Shetland
pony a little bit of DNA astray up any
extreme so you don't even know sometime
you wake up in the morning and you does
a little bit you're like where did that
come from
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know like working with these what
kind of wit is in my DNA you know I come
out on that stray animal bell you might
have a little femur you might not not
FEMA you might have a little bit of
ferret in you you know matter of that
furry bone that that fee merit and you
might have that in you so you know
that's what I'm saying I got that junk
in the trunk that Jay in the tray I
might be quarter Shetland pony back
there in the back you know what I'm
saying you might see from behind if
you're looking at me for mine you might
think you had on a parade route cuz I
got them hips I'm that HIPAA Gotham us
you feel me because I got them hip hip
hip bones you know and I y'all everybody
knows that I got the booty of a down
sent you know you know I got that D s
booty and I got the I got the booty of a
young black girl who made the dance team
but I'm glad you came out to the shows
Paola and uh ciao and that means I think
please and thank you or goodbye in a
pork you guess let's take another call
here here we go hey yo what's going on
man five real postman giving you a
costume and rainy rainy skies at
California right now just one of the I
don't know man I just I heard you on a
fighter in the kid and it made me
realize that everybody goes you know
goes through these these type of things
were
you know you're feeling all full of life
and happy to be around friends and
family and I don't know where something
just creeps up inside you and it brings
you down you know three to four days
weeks months to where you know I don't I
don't even want to be around friends I
don't want to be around family and then
then I'm constantly being myself down
from some no past mistakes and [ __ ] that
I've messed up on and regret and it was
just crazy today to hear you and Brian
discussing that - it made me realize it
you know sometimes you just got to talk
to somebody which I don't like to do I
just got to be quiet and be left alone I
feel you man I feel you there and that I
appreciate your call and thanks for
calling and uh and sharing that you know
I know it's sometimes not hard to it's
hard to do that and it's hard to do it
when you're leaving a voice message and
but I appreciate you I don't want you
thinking that that that went unnoticed
or unheard and you mentioned a couple of
things we don't want to talk to others
we don't want to do things we don't want
to go out and that that is that's
depressions that's that it's tricks
that's it's tricks it teach you to stay
by yourself stay over here do this stay
inside and it's there's scientific
evidence that depression it grows on
itself so with the less you bless you
reach out the less you have little
things over here you know make your
buddy a carrot oh I gotta talk to
freakin a lot Lee you know Lawrence
today make him a carrot I got it you
know I got to get a little nibble off a
Donna you know I make Donna Kerry you
got to reach out and that that's how you
break it you know I'm not telling you
what to do it but I am sharing from my
experience and I got to get my feet
moving I found once I'm in my head
if my brain is really moving then it's
[ __ ] tricking me because my feet are
supposed to be moving because my feet
move my brain will follow it they have
no choice
but if my brain starts moving it will
make my feet stay where they are because
my brain will think it's taking me
places man my brain taking me anywhere
my brain taking me down there behind the
alley you know and it's gonna [ __ ]
hit me with a broomstick or something or
make me think I'm not good enough or do
this or do that or do something you know
make me think about New York and Alf or
something watching internet and watching
you know booties and all of that it's
dirty sex I'm there
and we're better than that man that's
why we got to put our carats you got to
put you plant your carrots out there
when you feel them bad no matter what
I'm gonna call this person and check on
them it's a reverse I broke that
depression as a reverse psychology I
find if I call you know Todd and I call
little Eldred you know and I called big
G sure right next thing you know hey how
are you doing what's going on with you
and I and I hear what's up with them now
I've done something I've helped somebody
else a little I've been an ear for them
and now that the better parts of me feel
a little bit of empowerment and then I
get my feet move and I go to the gym I
go for a walk
I go do something I don't let my brain
walk I try not to anyway but yes like
you said we all do it and we all go
through it
and and those are things that work for
me
contrary action my brain tells me to
stay in bed I get out of bed you know I
don't want to go to the gym or do yoga
I [ __ ] go isn't that that cuz that's
the hardest thing I don't want you your
brains i man I don't want to do this
[ __ ] and then you [ __ ] do it showing
my brain who's boss and showing my
emotions who is boss because we have to
sometimes mean we have to be over to
ourselves you know but thank you for
your call man and keep your head up you
know and keep your feet moving and just
take the next right action do the next
right thing you need to make yourself
feel okay sometimes it's go get a bowl
of cereal
sometimes it's take a walk sometimes
just call someone else
but sometime you feel like sometimes I
feel like doing something and then I
just won't do it
even though I know it's good for me even
if it's a LITTLEST thing I do the
dishwasher clean the st. turn on some
music little things like that I don't
want to do it something inside of me is
like don't do it but I get them when I
do those things I get a little better
because then I'm taking control and I'm
not letting that black ship just sail
all around my waters but thank you for
calling man and yeah you you're not
alone there's a lot of us out there
together you and me are let's take one
more call man
and see what's going on homeward thank
ya this is John callin to you from
Covington Louisiana man gang gang big
Johnny boy out of that 985 son and
that's my hometown st. Tammany Parish
down there along the Tchefuncte River in
Covington Louisiana where Pistol Pete
Maravich had a he raised his children
and had a basketball gym built into his
attic and where Lee Harvey Oswald that
lho that third story depository bad boy
whose gun and in readin [ __ ] Grapes
of Wrath at the same time if he did it
where both of them have been from where
the tallest statue of Ronald Reagan in
America is Covington Louisiana home word
brother and I just got off work and
working Cracker Barrel Cracker Barrel
dude and that is where white people go
to eat collard greens our brother in
Covington out cook and since I love food
I got a food question for you my thing
is I grew up a crawfish boils I grew up
going on crawfish boil every year every
year three times a year sometimes and
the well yeah
crawfish are beautiful man [ __ ] you
know that's dirt that's dirt and that's
dirt salmon crawfish
that's the mahi-mahi of soil homework I
wouldn't ask you what's the weirdest
thing you ever ate at a crawfish ball
that they cooked in with the crawfish
for meeting with pineapple and I know
that sounds weird for pineapple in a
crawfish boil you cooking them with it
it tastes amazing dude try it out
sometime thanks so much for the podcast
love you Cody
big fan game brother thank you for
calling from my hometown man that's
awesome man that's so crazy to think
that somebody from my hometown listen to
this podcast and I'm from hometown and
I've just been living my life and this
these this summer circle and then now
he's connected and we're tied up here
I'll tell you this first of all
pineapples good on anything I don't care
where you find pineapple I don't care if
you [ __ ] you do in drywall you know
you know a couple of things a sheetrock
fall down and they got a [ __ ] a
couple of damp chunks back there from
the eighteen hundred's [ __ ] eat the
pineapple I don't care if you find a
couple of [ __ ] warm grams of
pineapple they need grandmother's apron
with Flint on it lint I mean eat the
pineapple man that's fuzzy pineapple
brought it's a delicacy in a you know in
France eat the pineapple but some of the
best things I've had at a crawfish boil
which I'm gonna have because I'm gonna
be going home for Easter and my brother
has a beautiful crawfish ball over there
off Kenmore Avenue and not batting rich
and they have yams they put sweet
potatoes in there you got a nanny night
Ayanna yeah but you put sweet potatoes
in there I've seen mushrooms I've seen
psychedelic mushrooms at a crawfish boil
and first they boil the crawfish and you
eat enough at em [ __ ] boomers dog
couple them [ __ ] brains sprout errs
next thing you know you boiling you
boiling moy and you don't know what's
going on then you [ __ ] hugging people
you don't even know bruh and you
sweating out of your tongue dude and you
[ __ ] think Mother Nature has your
best interests at heart bro and that's
that's when you want psychedelic
mushrooms
but I like yams in there I like oranges
or grapefruit halves you put those in
there cut them in half or slices like
what else do I like in a crawfish boil
I love yams and sweet potatoes they just
did it last year of our brothers and I
really really enjoyed it corn is popular
what else you could put in I liked those
sausages pieces of chicken you know I
like a sausage in there I like a good
hit of sausage venison good [ __ ] don't
give me that [ __ ] fatty fatty fatty
sausage bro this [ __ ] that looked like
it you know you know like it that
sausage that came off of my 700-pound
afternoon or whatever the show is give
me the good stuff that hit her but
that's it for me man there's some other
calls that came in I'll get to some of
them next week I got to go I got to go
honestly rest and I got a good meeting
tonight I'm sorry to yawn but one other
thing I will say that's good in a
crawfish boys carrots I like carrots in
there and that's full circle again you
know just thinking about my carrots like
what carrots damn I gonna put in front
of me that are gonna make me feel good
not on the outside because things on the
outside they only feel you can only feel
things on the outside with your hands
you know and I want to feel things with
the rest of me not my nothing I'm not
like my crotch or nothing but my heart I
want to feel things with my feelings you
know and so I want to put carrots out
there that make me you know that
challenged me in different ways and we
do that that's one of the things we talk
about and we think about here in this
podcast and I want to thank everybody
that came out in San Jose I'm gonna make
sure that I did all my responsibilities
I want to thank our advertisers Robin
Hood hair club skills shares and and I
just want to thank everyone I want to
thank you for listening being a part of
this I'm happy to be in your ears and
I'm and I have you in my heart man and
we do this [ __ ] you know we're gonna do
a lot of cool things over the years I
got nice fun plants you know I have a
vision that one day I'd like to be able
to open up like a
halfway house or in a place where people
could get some help in like half the
cities where I performed so then I can
what if imagine I could go perform in a
city and then have go to a meeting
afterwards or go to a meeting before you
know and just I don't know if that's
true but that can be a carrot from me
you know that can be a carrot for me but
thank you guys man thank you for
everything
be good to yourselves you know you
probably deserve it
and and let's get out of here like we
came in here man
learning as we go I want to thank also
my buddy Harrison Phillips and that's
he's part of that Bills mafia and he
took us on a tour of Stanford University
their football facility and stuff this
past weekend and it was awesome you know
Stanford only has 7,000 undergraduate
and 7,000 post-grad who are on campus at
a time about 1415 thousand students in
that that's crazy and to think they're
able to you know compete as well
athletically as they do and [ __ ] us see
that's something me and him both had in
common was we both thought [ __ ] USC bruh
and I hate to finish it up on that F
word but we did it man you guys be good
to yourselves man I'll see you next week
and uh and you deserve it you deserve it
and I deserve it and you reminded me
this week a lot of you guys Freesat just
through messages so many messages came
in there's a lot of them I can't get
back to him and so many I just and I
don't say that in a pompous way I just
can't I feel bad I can't reply to all of
them but I'll do what I can and you do
what you can be good
[Music]
celebrate ms
Seletar
[Music]
Oh
we all die
[Music]
Celie